[Musique]
un toboggan flambant neuf une piscine ou
encore un terrain de beach-volley au
complexe sportif Jacques Monod trappes
tout est prêt pour l'ouverture de la
plage ces jeunes visiteurs découvrent
les nouvelles installations
[Musique]
après 10 mois de travaux la ville
propose ce samedi un nouvel espace de
détente dédié aux familles 3,4 millions
d'euros ont été déboursés par la
municipalité pour construire jeux
aquatiques aire de détente et autres
cabines de plage 8 juillet au 16 août
sans interruption avec des nocturnes des
soirées spéciales des lotos des grandes
dictées géantes etc on donne du bonheur
à toutes les générations des plus âgées
au plus petit et comme vous le voyez le
site a été pensé pour donner sa place à
chacun un air de vacances
particulièrement apprécié par la
centaine d'enfants et de parents venus
nombreux ce jour-là on avait hâte que ça
ouvre et on est super fiers de ce parc
aquatique c'est la détente voilà début
des vacances on va poursuivre ça tout
l'été
permettent pas partir en vacances il
prend peu trop et parce qu'on des bons
vacances ici non mais il y a des
endroits on va concentre pas ça et ça
fait plaisir c'est bien ça plaît à tout
le monde au moins tous les tout le monde
peut jouer il y a beaucoup d'espace trop
bien ça m'a fait plaisir de venir ici
tous les ans on y viendra le plus
possible la plage est ouverte du 8
juillet au 19 août au complexe sportif
Jacques Monod de Trappes l'événement est
gratuit pour tous les trafics
[Musique]